merci Philipp bcer de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu dard membre du groupe Union
centriste rapporteur du projet de loi
immigration et donc membre de cette
désormais fameuse commission mixte
paritaire on va évidemment longuement en
parler est-ce que ce matin à quelques
heures de cette CMP vous êtes confiant
sur un accord je pense qu'il y a tous
les motif d'aller à un accord l'exercice
va être compliqué peut-être en prambule
autorisez-moi adresser des félicitations
à nos handbaluses et pour revenir à
votre préoccupation quand on voit les
quelques secondes d'informations avec
les problèmes géostratégiques les
problèmes économiques nos concitoyens
vivent dans un contexte que je
qualifierais d'anxiogène quand vous êtes
dans un contexte anxiogène le Parlement
a encore plus de motifs de trouver des
solutions et en particulier sur notre
sujet d'aujourd'hui qu le sujet
d'immigration donc pour vous il faut
sortir de cette CNP avec un accord à ça
un accord est indispensable parce que
les les enjeux sont trop importants pour
chacun ils sont nature différente si
vous êtes le gouvernement ou sa majorité
relative à l'Assemblée nationale vous
avez besoin d'un accord pour éviter un
échec politique cuisant si vous regardez
les choses avec les yeux du Sénat vous
avez une responsabilité dans l'équilibre
des institutions et donc il y aurait une
responsabilité institutionnelle pour
nous si notre Parlement n'a arrivez pas
à adopter un texte donc responsabilité
politique responsabilité
institutionnelle les deux sont très
lourde et justifie vraiment de faire
tous efforts pour arriver à un accord ça
sera une dé voocations bien sûr du
groupe centriste que j'aurai l'honneur
de représenter dans cette CMP on va
parler du fond et et des points qui
restent à trancher et sur lesquels vous
êtes prêt à faire des compromis mais
est-ce que les conditions sont réunies
pour un accord est-ce que cette
commission mixte paritaire elle n'arrive
pas trop tôt est-ce que le temps a été
nécessaire pour la préparer alors de
notre point de vue elle arrive
effectivement trop tôt et très vite
après un échec devant l'Assemblée
retentissant donc dans une situation
classique il faudrait laisser le temps
un petit peu de la cicatrisation après
un vote un petit peu singlant et un
temps de travail d'élaboration d'une
copie commue bon chacun le sait cela n'a
pas été le choix du président de la
République qui a voulu une prise de
position rapide positive ou négative
cela nous met une pression extrêmement
forte et nous fait travailler dans des
conditions qui sont assez inconfortables
mais la question du confort ou
l'inconfort n'est vraiment pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui nous ferons avec la
situation qu' nous est proposé ou qui
nous est imposé nous avons un bref délai
nous savons que nous avons une
obligation de résultat mais il nous
appartient de la respecter est-ce que
tout le monde sait qu'il y a une
obligation de résultat est-ce que tout
le monde est vraiment sur cette volonté
de trouver un accord jeis je crois que
tout le monde en est conscient c'est
vraiment un sujet qu'il fautir aborder
avec beaucoup d'humilité ça je n'ai pas
de doute sur le fait que tous les
acteurs ont la volonté d'aboutir à un
accord par contre je mesure assez bien
les contraintes de chacun pour les uns
le fait de ne pas vouloir faire évoluer
un texte dans lequel ils ont trouvé les
éléments de fermé qu'ils attendaient
pour les autres arriver à le faire voter
devant l'Assemblée nationale
euh les premers c'est l' les seconds
gouvernement et la majorité bien sûr
avec des avec des réticences puisque au
bout du bout quand même notre problème
de départ et ça on pourra tourner les
choses en tous les sens quels que soient
les les efforts de qualité rédctionnal
c'est que le sujet de départ c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et que celle-ci il manque au
moins 40 il manque au moins 40 sièges ça
personne ne peut le le résoudre en
l'état actuel en l'état actuel des
choses d'où la difficulté l'exercice
allez on va parler du fond du texte hein
puisque la discussion va se faire sur le
texte du Sénat mais chacun a fixé ses
lignes rouges alors quels sont les
points qui restent encore à trancher on
voit ça avec Alex
[Musique]
Poussard bonjour Alex bonjour ran
bonjour Philippe bonne carrière bonjour
et Alex la négociation va donc se faire
sur le projet de loi immigration durci
par la majorité sénatoriale de la droite
et du centre quels sont les points
important de discussion avec la majorité
présidentielle alors il y a plusieurs
points de négociation le premier on en a
beaucoup parlé il concerne la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension le
texte initial du gouvernement prévoyait
des régularisations de manière quasi
automatique la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat craignit un appel d'air
migratoire et a modifié la mesure en
prévoyant que ces régularisations se
fassent uniquement au cas par cas à la
discrétion du préfet et après un
contrôle de critères très strict pour
chaque dossier de chaque candidat sur
cette mesure un compromis est probable
entre les sénateurs les républicains et
la majorité présidentielle avec une
version qui sera très proche de celle du
Sénat en revanche il y a une ligne rouge
pour la majorité présidentielle c'est la
restriction de l'aide médicale d'État
l'aide médicale d'État qui on le
rappelle he permet de soigner les
étrangers en situation irrégulière les
sénateurs en novembre l'ont transformé
en aide médicale d'urgence avec un
panier de soins restreint c'est hors de
question pour la majorité présidentielle
hein la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale a supprimé cette
réforme alors les républicains
accepteraient de retirer cette mesure du
projet de loi immigration mais en
échange la première ministre ellisabeth
bornne a proposé de transférer cette
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État dans
un texte en janvier et cette réforme se
ferait sur la base du rapport qui a été
remis au gouvernement par l'ancien
ministre socialiste Claude Évin et
Patrick stéphanini ancien directeur de
campagne de François Fillon donc une
révision de l'aide médicale d'État mais
quelques adaptations seulement et Alex
il y a d'autres durcissements ajoutés
par la droite sénatoriale qui étit des
ligne rouge pour la majorité
présidentielle ah oui on le rappelle he
les sénateurs ont durci l'accès à la
nationalité par exemple en supprimant le
droit du sol automatique pour un enfant
dont les deux parents sont étrangers il
devra attendre 16 ans pour pouvoir
demander la nationalité française les
sénateurs ont également conditionné
l'accès à certaines aides sociales pour
les étrangers à une résidence rè d'au
moins 5 ans en France contre 6 mois
aujourd'hui et cette mesure elle était
encore discutée hier soir entre la
majorité présidentielle le gouvernement
et les républicains le camp de la
macronie essae d'exclure certains
étrangers certaines catégories
d'étrangers de ce durcissement on va
écouter géralde
Darman effet c'est pas une volonté du
gouvernement que de garder cet article
c'est une volonté notamment du Sénat et
des républicains on pourrait imaginer en
effet d' exclure lesé réfug par que les
réfugiés qui ont l'asile en France ils
peuvent pas attendre 5 ans pour protéger
leur famille chacun le comprend ça n'a
rien à voir avec une immigration
détournée économique il y a la question
de savoir quelle prestations social on y
met les APL les allocations familiales
l'allocation handicapé dans la
proposition des LR il y a l'ation
handicapé c'est pas très juste quand
quelqu'un handicapé il fait pas exprès
donc on pourra peut-être l'exclure en
effet de cette réforme et puis la
question de la durée voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut distinguer ceux qui
travaillent de ceux qui ne travaillent
pas donc est-ce que nous trouverons un
accord sur ce point nous le souhaitons
on n'est pas favorable à cet article et
après il faut faire un
pas voilà et ce lundi cette question des
prestations social pour les étrangers
n'était toujours pas réglé dans la
négociation avant la commission mixte
paritaire Philippe bonne Carrère on peut
dire déjà que de nombreux apports du
Sénat vont être conservés dans le dans
le texte de compromis donc ce sera
forcément une victoire pour les
sénateurs al je crois pas que ce sera
une victoire pour les sénateurs ce sera
une une victoire pour les institutions
françaises c'est-à-dire que le Sénat
aura prouvé qu'il était capable de
trouver un accord sur un taxe l'exercice
n'a pas été facile pour nous mais nous y
sommes arrivé je crois que les
centristes il ont pris une contribution
tout à fait majeure ayant pu adopter un
texte là où l'assemblée n'a pu le faire
nous avons une base de travail une base
de solution lors de la de l' CMP
beaucoup d'humilité nous avons un
travail à faire disposition par
disposition mais je ne permettrai pas de
parler de victoire par contre je suis
sûr d'une chose c'est qu'il y a s'il y a
un échec là on pourra parler de défaite
et il sera ce sera une défaite
collective si nous arrivons à un
résultat favorable nos institutions on
ont montré leur capacité à surmonter une
situation politique délicate et en
particulier le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale je
crois qu'à ce moment-là le travail aura
été fait c'est en ce sens que nous avons
une obligation de résultat en tout cas
j'aborderai toutes les discussions
d'aujourd'hui avec le sentiment d'une
obligation de résultat collective et
aussi d'une obligation de résultat
personnel on va rentrer dans le détail
hein des points qu'a rappelé Alex on
commence par laame l'aide médicale
d'État Alex et oui on le rappelle he les
sénateurs ont durci restreint le panier
de soins de l'aide médicale d'État l'ont
transformer en aide médicale d'urgence
est-ce que retirer cette mesure ajoutée
par les sénateurs et la mettre dans un
autre texte en janvier c'est une bonne
voie de sortie je pense que c'est une
bonne voie de sortie je voudrais d'abord
dire que chacun des points que vous
allez évoquer justifie un examen
spécifique vis-à-vis de nos nos
auditeurs nous ne sommes pas dans une
négociation au sens où l'un dirait voilà
je veux les articles 4 et 8 je dis ça
totalement au hasard le disant je tiens
au 6 et 7 et et au 18 il n'y a pas de de
négociation un article contre un autre
article c'est je crois l'esprit de
personne il y a une une série de sujets
qui sont posés que nous devons surmonter
et qui font l'objet d'un examen d'un
examen individuel donc pour
laame il y a un sujet
ame ce n'est pas blanc ou noir nous
comprenons très bien que la suppression
de la me soit un sujet il faut être tout
à fait attentif aux conditions de la
santé des conditions de la santé
publique mais l'ame a effectivement des
imperfections nous l'avions dit le
rapport stéphanini evvin l'a confirmé la
solution proposée par la premierre
ministre de faire un texte spécifique me
paraît une bonne solution là là-dessus
après derrière c'est uniquement des
questions de garantie je pense qu'elles
seront résolues dans la journée entre
les groupes ça veut dire que ça sera pas
un problème pour l'accord l'éventuel
accord en CMP mais juste un mot parce
que hier Gérald Haran sur C médicale
d'État il disait le problème c'est pas
le panier de soins c'est-à-dire la que
vous avez fait au Sénat le problème
c'est le statut de ceux qui ont accès à
cette ame est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
alors il y a plusieurs questions il y a
effectivement les question du statut il
y a des questions des délais il y a des
questions de je dire de verrou qui ne
figurent pas dans laame je pense
particulier au règle des ententes
préalables sur des soins importants et
puis a l'usage qui en effet en
particulier dans la période récente on a
vu une flambée des des dialyses donc on
a bien des mouvements spécifies qui se
font là-dessus il nous appartient de les
de les prévenir je le crois tout à fait
possible avec la me il y a un sujet qui
est complémentaire mais qui est très
important dans nos discussions qui n'est
pas forcément le plus populaire en tout
cas le plus connu c'est que à côté de
cette aide médicale de l'état la France
et la Belgique sont les deux seuls pays
au monde qui pratiquent ce que l'on
appelle le titre de séjour étranger
malade là il y a plus de difficultés
dans la mise en œuvre de ce texte et
nous serons très attentif au fait de le
ramener à une situation qui soit gérable
et qui ne soit pas trop inflationniste
pour notre pays c'est une situation où
notre pays est en atypicité si je pe
permettre d'employer ce terme l'autre
question Alex c'est la question des
prestations sociales et oui puisque les
sénateurs ont conditionné certaines
prestations sociales pour les étrangers
à 5 ans de résidence régulière au lieu
de 6 mois aujourd'hui est-ce qu'un
compromis est possible entre le Sénat et
la majorité présidentielle et lequel
alors je crois qu'on comprend is est
bien sûr possible je v d'abord évacuer
immédiatement un sujet j'ai vu des
déclarations tremblantes sur le fait de
dire vous êtes en train de mettre en
œuvre la préférence nationale c'est
totalement faux la discussion sur ces
contributions porte sur les allocations
dites non contributives c'est-à-dire que
toutes les situations liés au travail
sont traités dans les mêmes conditions
que je sois étranger ou que je ne sois
pas étranger si j'ai une activité
professionnelle j'aurais droit à des
allocations chômage j'aurais droit à des
indémités d'accident de travail j'aurais
droit des anabités journalières notre
sujet c'est uniquement ce qui relève de
la solidarité nationale c'est-à-dire ce
qui n'est pas contributif les
allocations familiales les allocations
logement la prestation handicap vous
avez entendu le ministre de l'Intérieur
il y a quelques secondes je pense
effectivement que nous trouverons un
accord sur sur le fait de ne pas
intégrer la prestation compensatoire et
la mettre hors des conditions de de
délai pour les allocation familial et
pour les allocations
logement le Sénat avait voulu un délai
de 5 ans qui est un délai qui est
parfaitement connu qui a été utilisé par
également les gouvernements de gauche
c'est le délai qui a été mis en place
pour le le RSA nous allons manifestement
avoir une discussion sur deux thèmes qui
travaillent pas travail probablement
faire une différence objective entre
l'appel à la solidariité nationale de
quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'un étranger qui
n'a pas d'activité sur notre sol et d'un
étranger qui a une activité sur notre
sol on voit bien que ça pourrait être 5
ans s'il n'y a pas d'activité si c'est
la solidarité pure et un délai de 2 ans
2 ans et demi 3 ans pour celui qui
travaille je pense qu'on peut arriver à
un accord mais j'insiste nous ne parlons
que d'allocation non contributive nous
sommes là sur l'étendue de la solidarité
tion pas sur un autre sujet les réfugiés
aussi pourraent être exclus de ce
durcissement oui ça il y a pas de il y a
pas de difficulté là-dessus le droit du
sol ah oui puisque le Sénat a également
durci l'accès à la nationalité par
exemple un enfant dont les deux parents
sont étrangers n'aura pas la nationalité
française automatiquement il devra
attendre 16 ans est-ce que ce
durcissement de la nationalité c'est
véritablement un point bloquant dans la
négociation je ne sais plus ce qui est
bloquant pas bloquant je pense qu'il
faut encore une fois faire preuve de
beaucoup d'humilité j'ai entendu il y a
quelques secondes dans l'introduction de
l'émission la présidente de l'Assemblée
dire que elle n'avait pas de ligne rouge
ou avit uniquement des lignes rouges
écarlates vous voyez que quand on est à
définir des nuances dans le dans le dans
les lignes rouges chacun essaie d'éviter
d'avoir des phrases définitives sur
cette question du droit
au le l'idée du Sénat n'est pas de
renverser la table et de modifier nos
règles qui par ailleurs ont souvent év
dans notre histoire nous nous sommes
posés deux questions la première
question c'est celle d'un jeune qui est
issu de deux parents qui sont eux-mêmes
étrangers et de lui poser la question
très
simple est-ce que vivant sur le
territoire français vous vous considérez
comme faisant partie de la Communauté
française ou ayant étélevé par deux
parents qui avaient gardé leur culture
étrangère vous vous santé d'une la
culture d'un notre pays la proposition
que nous avons faite consistant à dire
ce jeune fera une déclaration volontaire
entre 16 ans et 18 ans pour dire s'il
veut rester dans la nationalité
d'origine de ses parents ou s'il veut
faire partie de la Communauté française
me paraît pas un scandale c'est-à-dire
que nous ne fixons pas de conditions
nous ne nous ne disons pas à ce jeune tu
ne seras pas français on lui dit
simplement tu as la possibilité de faire
un choix quo c'est une question qui
n'est pas anormale dans la mesure où
votre éducation jeune homme ou jeune des
C demoiselle a été assuré par deux
parents qui étaient étrangers on leur on
ouvre un un choix sans blocage je ne
pense pas qu'on renverse les tables à
cet égard la deuxième question sur le
droit du sol c'est la situation tout à
fait spécifique que nous avons sur les
autr m à Mayotte en Guyane et dans les
Antilles à particulier dans à
Saint-Martin la pression migratoire pour
différentes raisons est extrêmement
forte sur ces territoirees et là nous
introduisons un délai qui avait déjà été
accepté pour Mayotte mais que nous
élargissons à la Guyane et à
Saint-Martin il faut que un des parents
soit en situation régulière sur le
territoire français depuis un certain
délai qui est différent suivant je
dirais le niveau de pression migratoire
ce serait un an à Mayot 9 mois en Guyane
et 3 mois à Saint-Martin tout simple
ement pour répondre à des problématiques
de pression
migratoire extrêmement fortes sur ces
territoires ce sont des mesure de bon
sens pour qui connaît un peu ces ces
territoires je je pense que les gens
peuvent peuvent en comprendre la
pertinence pour nos concitoyens de ces
outres mè on VO phipe bonc vous êtes
optimiste sur un accord il semble pas y
avoir de points extrêmement bloquants
hier Gérald haranin disait que s'il y
avait pas d'accord ce serait favoriser
l'arrivée de Marine Le Pen au pouvoir
vous êtes d'accord avec ça je suis
complètement d'accord avec avec cela en
de en deux temps euh un premier temps
c'est qu'eectivement s'il y a un vide
institutionnel d'autres viendront le le
le couvrir et on voit bien effectivement
que Madame Le Pen fait son miel de
toutes les peurs de tous les malheurs et
objectivement des difficultés de
l'action publique même si elle n'a
aucune solution et je pense que la
crainte de Monsieur Darman est juste
pour une deuxième raison en tout cas
c'est ce qui me me préoccupe c'est que
si le Parlement la représentation
nationale n'est pas en mesure de
résoudre les sujets et de répondre à la
question migratoire qui est une question
qui tarode nos concitoyens parce qu'elle
touche à l'identité et parce que il faut
bien le reconnaître les flux migratoires
ont beaucoup augmenté et chacun le sait
vont continuer à augmenter il va y avoir
une aspiration à dire mais on va
résoudre re ça par la voix du référendum
et il y a vraiment une chose sur
lequelle je voudrais insister c'est que
la voix du référendum est une voix qui
est bien sûr parfaitement possible mais
on ne change pas par référendum on peut
changer la loi mais on ne change pas nos
institutions pour changer nos
institutions pour changer la
Constitution il faut effectivement
l'expression directe de nos concitoyens
qui peent se faire par référendum et
mais il faut qu'il y ait un accord de la
représentation politique de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat et je vois bien
qu'il y a actuellement une petite
musique qui monte dans la société
française disant vous m'élisez président
derrière vous me donnez une majorité je
vous fais un référendum dans les
semaines qui viennent et ce référendum
nous libère de toutes les règles
institutionnelles tout pouvoir doit
avoir un contre-pouvoir il y a un
extrême danger euh à voir arriver cette
montée du référendum tout pour
l'obligation pour le morlement aboutira
des résultats oui merci Alex à tout à
l'heure oui on parlera du profil de ces
14 parlementaires qui composent la
commission mixte paritaire ce sera chif
dans le club on va voir l'actualité chez
vous pour terminer Philippe bon carer on
va à Albi dans le Tarme retrouver
alexandreau bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous journaliste au Tarne
libre avec vous Alexandre on va parler
de la ruralité avec notamment une
question sur la sécurité des élus
locaux bonjour bonjour monsieur le
sénateurc c'est voilà une des une des
préoccupations dont dont en tout cas on
entend beaucoup parler nous sur le
terrain euh c'est ben c'est le le le
fait que des élus locaux sont assez
régulièrement et de plus en plus ces
derniers mois confrontés à des
phénomènes de violence qu'elle soit de
violence verbale ou physique à le
rcontre on a eu plusieurs exemples dans
notre département ces derniers mois
souvent lié à des cas de de projets soit
type industriel ou ou d'infrastructure
je pense à l'autoroute entre castre et
Toulouse eu et on avait eu la visite en
juin dernier de Dominique fort la
Ministre chargée des collectivité
territoriale euh qui qui était venu
annoncer un Pack Sécurité alors la
question c'est est-ce que aujourd'hui on
on va assez loin pour pour assurer la
sécurité des des élus est-ce que c'est
pas le le le symbole de de d'un fossé
qui s'est creusé entre entre les élus et
et les citoyens bon d'abord heureux de
vous retrouver heureux de retrouver à
travers vous le la voix la la voix du
Tarne je vous assure que ça fait du bien
à Paris en particulier quand on est sur
les sujets migratoires alors la sécurité
des des élus c'est bien sûr un un sujet
c'est un sujet je dirais
multifactorial c'est un sujet qui tient
à une évolution de la société qui n'est
pas simple à à résoudre on a parler de
de décivilisation ou d'ensuvagement il y
a aussi une montée des incivilités et
c'est vrai que plusieurs élus locaux
Tarnis ont été victimes d'actes
absolument inaccepable je crois qu'il y
a aujourd'hui sur l'aspect législatif
tout est aujourd'hui en place c'est pas
des questions de d'infraction ou
d'échelle des peines c'est vraiment une
question de mise en je crois que notre
système judiciaire a parfaitement
compris qu'il y avait un problème les
préfets successifs ils sont extrêmement
attentifs et les EU locaux savent qu'ils
peuvent compter sur le soutien de l'État
non nous avons vraiment un enjeu
justement à la fois d'autorité
régaliennne je pense que la création de
trois nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
dans notre département n'est pas un
petit sujet pour montrer que le
territoire l'état revient dans les les
territoires et nous avons besoin aussi
de répondre encore mieux aux
préoccupations de nos concitoyens je
constate que par exemple les maisons
Fran service fonctionnent bien vous
savez c'est le fameux allé vert la
fameuse proximité une partie de nos
concitoyens ont pu se trouver
aujourd'hui privé de cette cette
relation avec les services publics il
faut les retrouver peut-être un dernier
élément pour vous dire aussi que notre
ruralité ch une deème question oui notre
ruralité change euh il n'y a plus de
vraie ruralité c'est un mélange entre
ruralité et et et et urbain donc c'est
devenu plus compliqué je pense parmi les
difficultés également j'en signale une
les problèmes de trafic de drogue qui ne
sont plus propre aux communes urbaines
que l'on retrouve aussi dans la ruralité
donc nous av notre société
a de nombreux facteurs à traiter mais je
pense que en tout cas la volonté est
très claire et nos collègues et lu loau
le seuent bien et Alexandre vous avez
une deuxième question al la deuxième
question vous vous avez commencé à en
parler c'est c'est notamment le fait que
bah depuis depuis le mois de juin c'est
c'est lancé France
ruralité et on voit et vous en faites
souvent l'écho au travers de votre blog
pas mal de d'actions sur le sur le
terrain la question c'est c'est là aussi
est-ce que est-ce que on va assez loin
aujourd'hui pour pour retrouver et
assurer l'attractivité des territoires
nous on on est très clairement frappé
par des des des problèmes d'accès aux
soins de d'accès au au services public
est-ce que les politiques publiques
aujourd'hui vont dans le bon sens est-ce
qu'elles identifient bien les les les
problématiques et est-ce que là aussi il
y a pas un un devoir de pédagogie auprès
des des des citoyens pour leur faire
comprendre que c'est pas un
millefeuilles supplémentairire
euh parce que voilà souvent la clarté
est un peu un peu mise de côté sur sur
la présentation de ces éléments alors
sur la pédagogie vous accorderez à vos
braves sénateurs d'essayer de faire
cette pédagogie ce qui fonctionne bien
c'est d'une part France ruralité avec
les programmes pour les petites villes
et la prochaine étape nous appelons les
villages d'avenir la sélection des com
il y a plus de 50 communes tarnaises qui
ont été candidates à ce programme
village d'avenir on aura juste avant
Laan Nol la réponse sur sur ce point
fonctionne également bien
l'accompagnement financier en terme
d'investissement entre laadter laadcile
les moyens financiers sont là reste
effectivement deux sujets à résoudre les
déserts médicaux et la capacité à
construire dans nos territoires ruraux
c'est le sujet d'Usan sur lequel vous me
savez passionné au côté des communes
rurales tarnais merci merci Alexandre
Renaud
du Tarne libre on regarde votre une prêt
pour l'hiver le département sécurise les
routes c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup Alexandre Renaud d'avoir
été avec nous à très vite merci Philippe
boncère d'avoir été notre invité bon
courage pour cette soirée qui s'annonce
peut-être longue on suivra évidemment
tout ça sur nos antennes et cette
commission mix paritaire merci d'avoir
été avec nous